In the first video
on Social Security,
I keep talking about how the
tax that you pay for Social
Security is called the FICA tax.
What I want to do in
this video is, one,
let you know what FICA actually
stands for, and then think
a little bit about how it
is actually calculated.
So first, what
does it stand for?
Literally, it just stands for
Federal Insurance Contributions
Act.
That's the acronym.
And so it'd be FICA,
and then some people
will call it FICA tax.
And this isn't just to
support Social Security,
or to be technically correct,
to support the old age
survivors and
disability insurance.
Part of FICA tax is for that,
and part is for Medicare.
And so to make things
clear, the part
that is Social Security,
or what we associate
as Social Security, which
is really the OASDI--
did I get that right?
OASDI.
So part of it is
for Social Security,
and then that part is
12.4% of the gross salary.
But half of this is paid
for by the employer,
half is paid by the employee.
And we'll do a
calculation in a second.
So 6.2% and 6.2%.
The part that's paid
by the employer, that's
part of the payroll tax,
stuff that the employer
pays above and beyond
the gross income
that they're giving
to the employee.
And we'll do that
calculation in a second.
The other thing that FICA
tax is used for is Medicare.
And this is for a total amount
of 2.9% of an employee's
gross salary, or 1.45% from the
employer as part of the payroll
tax and 1.45% from the employee.
And if you add
these two things up,
you get 15.3% total FICA tax.
15.3% where, once again, half
is paid by the employer and half
is paid by the employee.
Now, let's just do a calculation
so that it makes a little bit
more tangible sense
of what I'm even
talking about with
this FICA tax.
So let's imagine that
you make $100,000 a year.
And it's a nice number,
because it makes the math easy.
Then your employer--
employer, employee,
let me write it like this.
Employer, employee.
So for Social
Security, your employer
will contribute 6.2% of this.
So above and beyond paying
the $100,000 gross salary,
they will also pay
6.2%, or $6,200.
And the employee
will also pay $6,200.
And that will be deducted
from their paycheck,
so what they get will
be net of the $6,200.
And then for Medicare--
let me do that in pink.
Then for Medicare,
the employer will
contribute $1,450,
once again above
and beyond the gross
salary of $100,000.
And the employee will pay $1,450
out of their gross salary.
So the total amount that
is paid by the employer
is $7,650 in payroll tax
for this one employee.
And the total amount
by the employee
is the exact same
amount, $7,650.
So just to be clear, if you
wanted to hire an employee
and pay them $100,000
in gross salary,
you actually would have to set
aside $100,000 and the $7,650.
So the employer-- the
total that the employer's
paying-- or let me just
think of it this way.
The total that the
employer has to set aside,
if you include the
salary, is going
to be $107,650 so they
can cover the gross salary
plus this payroll tax over here.
The net that the
employee is getting--
and actually, this
isn't even the net.
I shouldn't even
call it the net.
The employee, after
paying FICA taxes,
is going to be the
$100,000 minus the $7,650.
But I won't even write
that number down.
I mean, what is that?
That's $92,350,
because that's before
paying just the
traditional federal income
tax and the traditional
state income taxes.
So that's going to cut
it down a good bit.
So the employee's going
to take home probably
on the order of
$60,000 to $70,000,
so above and beyond
this thing right here.
So even though the
employer's paying this much,
the employee's
getting a lot less
in terms of what they
get to take home.
Now, one thing that
I think that is worth
mentioning is unlike
traditional federal income
tax-- and traditional
federal income tax
the first several 10s of
thousands of dollars you make
are not taxed.
And then as you go
up the brackets,
each incremental dollar, as you
enter one bracket or another,
you start to pay a higher
percentage on those.
The FICA tax is
actually very different.
Some people would even call
it a regressive income tax.
And that's because
you only pay the FICA
tax on the first
$106,000-- or at least this
is the numbers in 2011.
You only paid on
the first $106,800.
So someone who makes $200,000
will pay the same FICA tax
as someone who makes $106,800.
So you only pay on the
percentage below that.
And the reason why is that
the person making the $200,000
will get the exact
same benefits, as well,
as the person who pays $106,800.
And this number, essentially,
they try to index it roughly
to inflation.
So it will go up over time.
But to some degree, someone
who makes, let's say-- well,
someone who makes
below this threshold
is going to pay this percentage.
Between them and
their employers,
they're going to pay this
percentage of their income.
Well, someone who makes
much more than this
will actually pay a smaller
percentage of their income,
but they'll end up
getting the same benefits.
And so that's one reason why
it's considered regressive,
is that as you make
more money, you're
actually paying a
smaller percentage
of your income on FICA tax.
And the other reason why
it's considered regressive
is actually on the benefit
side, because obviously someone
who-- if you have two people
receiving Social Security
benefits-- so you have
this person-- so this
is when they turn 65.
Let me put it this way.
So let's say that
you have two people.
They work their whole lives.
And let's say they
both retire at 65,
although that retirement
age is increasing.
It's slowly being indexed up.
And then they retire.
It's known that the wealthier
people or wealthier--
and there's also demographics
based on race and things
like that.
But it's known that wealthier
people actually live longer,
so they actually get benefits
for a longer period of time.
So they're actually able to
get their benefits for longer.
So it depends where
you fall into it.
Likely that even though
there's this cap,
someone higher up the
income chain also probably
did pay more into it.
But they're also
getting a bigger check
for paying more into it.
The check that
you eventually get
is based, to some degree,
on what level of FICA tax
you were paying.
And they're very
well likely to be
able to collect these payments
for longer than someone who
maybe doesn't have quite the
same, I guess, quality of life
and doesn't actually
live as long.